[Music]
[Music]
yo what's up what's going on tell us
tell us about your plate well we do
whole hog barbecue here that's what
makes us special and we cook it with
just wood there's no gas in here on the
smokers it takes about 12 to 15 hours to
cook a pig that way we cook the pig
until it's an internal temperature of
193 all that fatty goodness just starts
to melt at that temperature and then it
just kind of melts and just pours
through the meat and the meat instantly
changes texture this is a sauce that we
just started making I'm calling it xxxx
red it's just a spicy red sauce tomato
base there's some vinegar and we cook it
underneath the pig and it's just getting
dripped on and getting a layer of smoke
from that bottom of the pit Wow
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
where are we where'd Lexington barbecue
place in North Carolina what were you
guys known for
we're known for smoking pork shoulder
all we do is salt our me we don't baste
it we don't inject it we don't put any
sauce on it and show you order whatever
what am I about to eat like explain to
me because I'm a original barbecue place
I've always done with the slaw shop
barbecue french fries Hush Puppies also
I love you guys been around grandpa
started in 1962 used to be a gas station
and a radio station I think it had two
tables in it built it since then we're
selling average legal fee 7,000 people a
week right now yeah I mean nothing's
changed really
we still fire the pits the same way the
same amount of time
[Music]
my name is Sam Jones
welcome to skylight Inn barbecue so our
family started skylight the summer of
1947 this year actually makes 70 years
that we've been doing the same thing
every single day my grandfather opened
at the age of 19 a third grade education
one of the smartest men you ever made in
your life the staple is whole hog pork
chop by hand that was cooked for 18
hours
lightly seasoned top with a piece of
cornbread that the recipe has been the
same for almost 100 years what a
coleslaw recipe sitting on top of that
that's 70 plus years old that's not just
a paper boat with pork in it that's a
piece of North Carolina history and this
sauce that he just poured on my bath in
sauce it comes out real easy on your
jeans barbecue you shouldn't be defined
by sauce it should be defined my house
prepared and what it is in a North
Carolina Quahog wood-fired barbecue its
what barbecue is Sam Jones University
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
started on my corn instead me too we did
have mostly family Sam my brother MA and
my wife and dominated get my grant some
on I did a little bit of mechanic that's
why you guys with mechanic shirts here
we do a hole in the back and and do
mechanic up front we change and went off
to public you what's special about your
barbecue sauce the sauce yeah what's in
the sauce vinegar pepper red pepper jack
that's it once you eat it one time
you're gonna come back and we have
beautiful all over the world did you say
you eat that's for breakfast yeah
[Music]
[Music]
my name's Chris bear we're at Swetman
barbecue in Holly Hill South Carolina
serving whole hog barbecue cooked over a
real wood fire the restaurant proper has
been here since 1977 originally started
founded by bub Swetman he started
cooking whole hogs in his backyard
selling it out of back his pickup truck
in the 50s came popular enough that he
decided to buy this old farmhouse
mustard sauce is just I mean really is
that's all it is it's not a fancy
barbecue sauce it's just gonna be
mustard well there's sugar a little bit
of vinegar a little bit of pepper so
good I honestly can't stop eating it
it's kind of a regional Low Country
South Carolina thing but it's what
Sweatman's has done since its inception
just complements the court perfectly you
get that a little bit of smoke a little
bit of fat then you get that sweetness
and that Tang the mustard kind of cuts
through how rich that meat is it's a
perfect combination we appreciate it
thank you thank you guys for coming man
go back right that's nothing that's
third yeah
[Music]
you
[Music]
what is it that you guys are doing here
that makes you beef barbecue this is
pretty much a Texas thing start off with
Certified Angus beef the USDA prime
brisket put our dry rub on it then we
smoked it over all wood and offset
indirect smokers that we custom-built
ourselves and it takes about 18 and 20
hours to cook the brisket all the way
through so we've got the lean Mendoza
bliss to get down here yeah it's a bad
side over here this lays over the top of
the lean muscle there's a little bit of
burnt ends from the fatty side you vote
the smoke with yourself with your bare
hands yeah equal weld yeah where'd you
learn how to weld I'm trying to figure
out how to make barbecue pit
how long did that take a couple years
what was so shitty about other barbecue
hits that you're like I have to make
this one yeah I made once it's
specifically designed to cook brisket
and that's after years of trial and
error
thank you have it
[Music]
you
[Music]